from a show about humans versus titans
to a show about
war racism injustice and freedom attack
on titan has come a long way now hasn't
it with season four coming to a rather
cliffhanging conclusion we can call it
the season that revolutionized anime
and gave us one of the greatest main
characters of all time so as a tribute
to the series i'm going to take a look
at 10 of the best moments in the fourth
season of attack on titan
also a quick reminder to subscribe to
our channel if you haven't because we've
got a lot more content like this coming
your way with that said let's dive into
the list
talk about bad karma you enter and
massacre an entire city of malians
and they come back to massacre yours you
eat one of their titans in the most
brutal way possible
well they just eat your legs this scene
not only showed marley's skill and
espionage but showed peak's potential to
be a great actress her convincing powers
were insane
and even managed to give gabby some
lessons on morality also let's not
forget that shot of the attack titan now
looking like the true devil of parodies
overall this can be called one of the
greatest cliffhanger season endings of
all time
and eren's battle call for rhino was
both chilling and suspenseful
we may have to wait yet another year but
i'm looking forward to the confrontation
between the two parties
three titans versus one the
possibilities are endless
and that's why this scene is such a
strong cliffhanger
[Music]
when a character can turn into a large
ape who's a pro baseball player
and a mass murderer you gotta wonder
about his origin story
zeke at first wasn't a face to anyone
like to see the hatred of killing
humanity's greatest commander still lay
in our minds and even though levi gave
him the punishment he deserved
zeke still ranked top in isaiah's i'm
never gonna kill them list
fortunately to justify his experience of
plot armor we got a flashback of his
past which once again proved that no
person in the attack on titan universe
has ever had a happy beginning
grisha back in the day was a much more
motivated and a psychologically abusive
fire that no kid would like to have
that's when we realized that only a
fragment of what happened back in season
three was revealed
zeke tried to convince his parents to
give up for their own safety but when
they didn't he had to spill out
everything for the man he knew
this not only made zeke yeager a tragic
anti-hero but also a character we can
sympathize with
[Music]
[Music]
coming in at number eight is erin's
conversation with mikasa and armin
so moving back to erin not only does he
decide to do a prison break but to also
casually walk in and have a chat with
his old friends okay perhaps
chatting is the wrong word but how about
emotionally traumatizing one character
and physically abusing the other yep
this scene may just pass on as another
scene filled with overbombastic dialogue
but don't forget the words
and punches that were exchanged in the
process aaron entered the room as armin
and mikasa's childhood friend but walked
away after shattering his relationship
with both of them and we finally got to
know why mikasa was such a flat
character through the first two seasons
so props to isaiah for finally
correcting his own writing mistakes
next up we have levi and the survey
corps entrance in mali
normally when you see your favorite
characters after a time skip that puts a
smile on your face but in attack on
titan
it does the exact opposite i know we had
quite a few hype moments with the acumen
entrances and the appearance of jean and
the rest of the gang but let's not also
forget the casualties both sides
suffered and if you're a manga reader
you might note that little detail studio
mapper added to make the morality of
each character more ambiguous who are
the good guys who are the bad guys the
eldians and their titans are trying to
defend their nation and the soldiers of
parodies are taking their revenge no
one's right or wrong
and at the end of the day you can't
really pick sides okay well perhaps we
all hate gabby but at least admit you
rooted for the rest of the characters
[Music]
next let's move on to another tragic
backstory that's bertolt reiner and
annie's mission on parodies
honestly this season of attack on titan
is like one of those truth-revealing
arcs in higurashi
every mystery plot thread and character
arc the previous seasons built up was
either resolved or justified the same
can be said for our original malian trio
reiner's words at the top of the wall
before the reveal annie's desire to see
her father all of these were given a
purpose through the backstory we also
got more character insight into rhino as
we realized how tragic his own past is
and how he finally built up the courage
to lead the team after getting kicked by
annie and like most flashbacks in attack
on titan
in the end every character had a reason
for doing what they did there were no
villains in attack on titan
just flawed people
[Music]
foreign
those who started sympathizing with zeke
we deeply regret to inform you that next
up is the third round of levi
and zeke by now even without watching
the scene you should know how this works
levi ackermann's another arnold's
voldigold but with blades you can't kill
him you can't hurt him and even if you
turn all his comrades into titans he
still catches up to you because this man
has no regrets
at first zeke and levi seem like the
perfect duo like two rivals who can't
help but work together then
zeke turns the tables transforms levi's
whole squad into titans and executes the
perfect backstab of all time
at this point levi has faced enough
tragedy that he's grown numb to him he
reminisces with his squad for one last
time
and the slashing begins zeke's cgi titan
couldn't once again take down the
ackerman and though it wasn't some
brutal slugfest like last time levi won
the round easily and taught the elder
jaeger brother the consequences of
messing with an ackermann
coming in at number four is the opening
sequence of season four
war can be brutal and that's something
you've heard more than a million times
have you ever seen a war with explosive
trains and overpowered titans once again
studio mapper
just built the infrastructure of the
scene using the manga and added their
own formula to make this scene extra
brutal dead bodies
explosions blood splatters brutal deaths
all of them amalgamated to give us a
well-directed scene that showed how
horrible the war is and also let's not
forget about ryan and zeke who stole the
spotlight of the scene with their
transformations
gabby's energetic character introduction
and marley's brutal war tactics the very
first attack on titan scene directed by
mapa ended with flying colours and at
the same time
we had to stare in awe at the power of
mali surely aaron is no match for this
well at least that's what we thought
next up at number three is erin's fight
with the warhammer titan
what's the most creative way to slay a
titan ask aaron yeager he may have been
the crying and screaming protagonist in
season one but now he's back with more
muscle
more brain power and little to no
morality in this fight evan uses a lot
of strategies compared to his previous
fights with titans and was even quick to
figure out the trick of the warhammer
titan he did get some help from mikasa
and his squad mates but he did most of
the job and the eating the sequence of
him devouring lara taibo with jaw titan
as the nutcracker was one of the most
brutal scenes in attack on titan and all
that time i had my mouth open wondering
how much aaron had changed remember when
i said eren's no match for mali after
this scene
it was the other way around
[Music]
coming in at number two is armin's
transformation in liberio all this
season we've been talking about aaron
and marley so let's shine the spotlight
on our blonde strategist shall we after
getting burnt to death armin seems to
like burning other people to death
that's exactly what happened during his
transformation in liberio however unlike
erin armin seems to regret what happened
and seems depressed about the events
looking at it from a certain perspective
you have to sympathize with him he
sacrificed himself for the colossal
titan with a firm resolve but then he
was resurrected
forced to wield the power of the
colossal titan and then thrown into a
racist war
where he had to kill people like i said
you find tragedy all around season four
but if you divert away from that
pessimistic viewpoint you can also call
this scene one of the best anime
transformations of all time
oh taking our first spot is the
ever-famous errands transformation in
liberio how long has it been
three years well if you weren't a manga
reader you never know how much hype we
were for this scene if you're an anime
only viewer then i can tell you without
a doubt your jaw fell onto the floor
during the grand reveal this scene isn't
just one of the greatest scenes of
attack on titan but the scene that
changed the main character
showed who held the upper hand and
showed the potential of the show as a
whole the tension was neatly built up
during the conversation of erin and
reiner and then with one flash of
lightning the narrative of attack on
titan flipped of 180 and turned to be
one of the greatest stories ever written
surely this is a scene that will be
talked about for ages on social media
so there goes our picks for 10 of the
best attack on titan season 4 moments
all our prayers are for studio maplight
to adapt the rest of the series and
bring it to a successful conclusion and
judging from the popularity of the
series
i can definitely tell our prayers will
be answered let me know your favorite
moments down below in the comments and
make sure to like the video if you
enjoyed it that's it for today anime
fans and i'll see you in the next video
you